Salut à tous, c'est Pécheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui nous sommes à Narbonne pour une session de pêche à l'aimant
et nous avons accueilli un invité de marque
Il s'agit de Leigh de la chaîne Bondi Treasure Hunter ainsi que de sa copine Nicki.
Nous les avons amenés sous un pont stratégique
en dessous duquel nous avons déjà trouvé des armes ainsi qu'un coffre fort au fond de l'eau.
Ils ont adoré l'endroit et on a directement commencé à enchaîner les belles découvertes.
Leigh a découvert cette magnifique hache dans un premier temps.
On en a aussi profité pour lui apprendre quelques notions de français.
Lancer, lancer d'aimant !
Ensuite, Leigh y a remonté des petits boulets de canons.
Magnifique découverte aussi.
Un petit bloc de rouille s'est ensuite accroché à mon aimant.
Il avait étrangement la forme d'un petit pistolet.
Dans le doute, on a donc décidé de taper dessus pour voir si la rouille se détachait.
Et on a bien fait.
Puisqu'il s'agissait en fait d'un pistolet encore dans son holster.
Celui-ci est certainement dans l'eau depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
On a fait une vidéo d'unboxing dans laquelle on le sort de son holster.
Elle arrivera bientôt sur la chaîne.
Quentin a ensuite trouvé un petit paquet de munitions encore entier.
Munitions de la Seconde Guerre mondiale, probablement de KAR98.
Regardez son état.
On a vraiment réussi à sortir pas mal de choses en très peu de temps.
Sympa.
Je vais le garder comme ça celui-là, on ne va pas le nettoyer.
Pour la collection.
Ensuite, un employé communal de la mairie de Narbonne était super sympa et nous a aidé à évacuer les dégés.
On a donc décidé de continuer la pêche un petit peu plus loin.
Regardez, je viens de trouver un porte-clé de la Fédération Française de football.
Avec une seule étoile.
Donc c'est un ancien.
Il commence à pleuvoir.
Bondi qui vient de Hollande va se moquer de nous
Ce n'est pas de la pluie
Non, il ne pleut pas en France
Ok.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a là ?
Oh, c'est une pédale de vélo
Oui.
Ils me poursuivent
Un morceau de vélo
Ces vélos
La pluie et les vélos
Oui, il pleut comme à Amsterdam
Quentin pêche sous la pluie
Ce n'est pas la même pluie que...
Dans le nord.
Il pleut mais il ne fait pas froid.
En tout cas, ça fait plaisir.
On a amené Bondi sur un spot où il y avait un peu de tout.
Oui, c'est sympa.
C'est ça qui est sympa.
Il a dit que c'était son premier boulet de canon.
Il me semble.
Donc c'est pas mal depuis le temps qu'il pêche
Il nous manque juste la caisse et le coffre.
Ouais, le coffre fort
Ca reste une belle découverte
Un faux Zippo
Je ne sais pas si il va arriver.
Il est trop rouillé
Un véritable Zippo se serait ouvert
Ah, oui, un vrai se serait ouvert
C'est tout ce que je peux obtenir.
Et encore ?
Des pièces, des pièces, des pièces.
J'ai encore des clefs
Regardez, il y a tout un trousseau de clefs
C'est quoi ?
Il y a un slip, un caleçon.
Nice !
Un boxer
Un gros slipe
C'est un XXL.
Ah, c'est un XXL.
On s'est décalés.
On est toujours en centre de Narbonne
Juste en dessous du château.
C'est bien Rasta
Allez.
Pêchons à l'aimant ici
Oh, tu en a un autre.
Yeah.
C'est plein de ces déchets
Gaz hilarant
Une autre bouteille de gaz hilarant
Yeah, yeah.
Belle trouvaille mon pote
Triste trouvaille
Il en a une aussi
Thank you.
Bien joué.
Encore du protoxyde d'azote, il y en avait partout ici
Tu l'as eu ?
Oui, juste ici
Okay.
Je fais frotter mon grappin
Ok tu as raison
C'est si lourd
Yeah.
Je vais essayer de l'avoir au grappin
Ca va être difficile
Il est juste en dessous
Je crois que je l'ai
Oh, yeah.
Ca vient
Regarde toutes les bulles ici
Oh mon dieu !
Il vient
Qu'est-ce que j'ai ?
C'est une moto, non ?
Oui un cadre de moto
Oh, mon dieu
Je savais que c'était lourd !
Je viens d'avoir un cadre de moto !
En plein milieu de la ville
Je l'ai eu grâce au grappin
On dirait qu'il y a une veste dessus
À ce moment-là, Bondy nous explique qu'il adore cet endroit
parce qu'il est très facile de passer par ici
pour jeter des motos entières.
On était juste en face de ce point emblématique de Narbonne
qui va certainement être détruit dans pas longtemps.
Dammit.
Tu t'en sors ? Besoin d'aide ?
Oui je veux bien
Essayons avec le grappin
Je lance le grappin
Ok, je l'ai
Oh, mon dieu ! C'était quoi ?
Je sais ce que c'est
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Il a une chaise
C'est un gros plot
Ok, on peut l'avoir ?
Il y a du béton avec, oui on peut l'avoir
Quentin, viens nous aider.
Prend ton aimant
On a besoin de trois aimants
C'est l'objet dont Quentin parlait
Les jolis plots avec l'emblème de la ville
All right.
Tu viens ?
Ouais.
Ok, on est dessus
Il arrive
Regardez la taille !
Yeah.
C'est un bon
Okay.
Il faut les retirer
Yeah.
Attendez, attendez
J'aurai pu l'avoir
Pouvez-vous retirer un aimant ?
Non.
Allez, on y va, on y va.
Je vais essayer
Yeah.
1,2,3
Doucement, doucement
Non, non, non, non.
On y est presque
Oh, yes.
Je sais que ça allait être du travail aujourd'hui !
Oui, bien joué
C'était dramatique mais regardez !
C'est l'emblème de la ville
Oui mais gars
À ce moment-là, Leigh nous a appelés
parce qu'il avait repéré quelque chose d'énorme au fond de l'eau.
Oh, il y a quelques bulles
Oui des bulles
Okay, intéressant
C'est très lourd mais les bulles signifient que ça vient
C'est tellement lourd !
Quentin ?
Tu as besoin d'aider ?
C'est fou
Ok il arrive
Tu viens, Quentin ?
C'est surement la plus grosse découverte du jour
C'est énorme
Juste ici
Ca a la forme d'une moto
On a besoin de plus de monde
Yeah.
Comment on dit "Venez nous aider" en Français ?
Est-ce que des gens sont motivés pour nous venir nous aider ?
J'ai une paire de gants en plus
On a des gants, en plus.
Pour tirer ce qu'il y a là
Attention, par contre si ça lâche d'un coup,
de ne pas tomber en arrière
Je m'occupe de ca côté
Vous êtes prêts ?
Allez.
Un, deux, trois.
Ça va ?
Ca a lâché
Imagine, c'est la plus grosse découverte du monde.
C'est le Trésor des Templiers
Il bouge facilement
Juste ici, je pense
Okay, vous êtes prêts ?
J'ai des flashbacks de ma pêche à Paris
Yes.
Il vient !
Allez.
On pose la corde et on marche dessus
On peut voir.
Une norme moto.
Yeah.
Regardez le public là qui nous acclame.
On envoie un aimant ici aussi
Merci à vous de nous aider.
Ça vous fait le sport de la journée.
Regarde toute cette essence, il faut la sortir de l'eau
Et oui elle est lourde...
On a une personne de plus ici
Il a l'air costaud lui aussi
Et il a compris
On a aussi des filles fortes
Oui on a besoin de toi mec
Yeah.
Il vient à contre cœur
Vas-y.
Envoi le à l'avant
L'aimant
On passe une bonne journée les gars ?
Yeah.
Okay.
Mets l'aimant dessus aussi
Juste pour le supporter
On et de deux
Maintenant un troisième
Pardon
Okay.
Voilà et de trois !
Il est bloqué lui ?
Peut-être plus de monde sur celui-ci
Okay.
Pour la renverser
Deux personnes
Un deux trois
Oh mon dieu
Ok regarde ça
C'est pas une petite moto
Un deux trois
oh mon dieu
Oh, elle est belle.
Je peux attacher la roue
Tu quoi ?
Yeah.
Oui c'est possible
On va pendre Quentin par les pieds
vas y mon frère
Essaie de le tenir
Je suis debout dessus
Huh ?
Oh yeah.
Je suis debout sur la corde donc je ne peux pas bouger
Okay.
parfait ça c'est fait
Ok on a le droit à des applaudissements
Merci !
Nous n'avons jamais eu droit à ça
Et en plus on ne l'a pas encore sortie
Okay.
Très bien
On peut tirer celui-là ?
On peux tous se mettre sur lui ?
Okay.
Tout le monde sur celui-ci
Oui je vais essayer celui-là
Yeah.
Je viens avec vous les gars.
Plus de monde !
On a besoin de plus de monde
Plus de monde s'il vous plait
Deux personnes en plus
Allez
On a besoin de 2 personnes en plus
Il arrive
On a besoin de plus de monde
Tu parles français
Demande leur
On a besoin de deux personnes en plus.
Okay yo.
Il y a un mec musclé ici
Ah, bah voilà.
Venez
il vient
Parfait ils arrivent
Yeah.
C'est top
Les filles sont là
Yes, here.
C'est génial
On a besoin d'aide.
Pour tirer.
Il arrive
Ah il a un enfant
Ah.
Et une glace surtout
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Je pense qu'il y en a
Attend, on essaie ?
Il y a plus de monde qui arrive
Prenez la corde.
Allez on, go, go, go, go.
Attention.
Il y a quelqu'un qui a couru de l'autre côté
en faisant le tour pour venir nous aider.
Il est en train d'arriver.
J'espère qu'il est musclé
Il y a la plaque du matriculation.
Les renforts arrivent.
Venez.
On a besoin d'aide.
On a une moto à repêcher.
Bravo pour le footing.
Ouais, mais la barrière, elle va nous gêner aussi.
Je pense qu'on va y arriver.
Le plus possible sur celle-là, elle est attachée.
Cette corde est la principale.
Okay, nous sommes prêts ?
Allez.
Allez, on va avoir une break.
Ça c'est ouais, dans les...
On va faire une break pour le record.
Ça doit faire 300 kilos avec le poids de l'eau en plus.
Regarde la foule, c'est incroyable.
Peut-être qu'il faut l'attacher à Rasta aussi.
Rasta ?
Okay.
T'es prêt ?
1, 2, 3, 4.
Okay, posez la corde
Je suis juste venu pêcher à l'aimant en France
Et voilà ce qu'on trouve
Okay.
On partage ?
Euh, on fait deux groupes ?
Ouais.
Okay.
Sur cette corde ?
Ouais, c'est ça.
Nice.
C'est bon ?
Vous êtes prêts à récupérer celle-là ?
Ouais.
1, 2, 3.
Allez ! Allez !
Allez !
Oh mon dieu
Oh !
Bien joué !
Bravo à tous.
Merci, merci.
Merci.
Et vous en particulier merci
Merci à tous.
Légendes !
Merci.
C'est bon ? On la relève ?
On la remet debout
Ouais.
Mais pas trop !
Yeah.
Okay.
Mets la moto sur la béquille
Comme ça ?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, parfait
Nikki, on va bien.
On va aller sur ce côté.
Ouais !
On va pas tomber dans le canal.
On est obligé, on est obligé.
Bon bah là, vu que la moto est probablement volée,
Baptiste va appeler pour donner le numéro de la plaque d'immatriculation.
On va appeler la police parce que c'est une plaque
d'immatriculation récente
On va demander.
Voilà la bête.
On a donc appelé la police qui arrive.
Ils ne nous ont pas encore dit si elle était volée ou pas.
On en saura plus bientôt.
Elle est pas volée.
Elle est pas volée ?
Non, elle est pas volée.
Ah ouais ?
Oui.
Ouais, ouais, elle est pas volée.
Elle est pas volée.
Okay.
C'est la mairie qui la récupère alors, ouais ?
C'est la mairie à voir.
Ouais.
Okay.
Ouais, bah...
Ouais.
Donc on fait quoi ?
Nous on la met trop de côté pour l'instant ?
C'est okay pour les filmer de dos ?
Ouais, c'est okay.
Ouais ?
Quand vous les voyez tout là,
vous voyez, c'est très bien.
Bah nous d'habitude,
on la revend au fer au ferrailleur
Ouais, mais vous voyez,
Avec la mairie avant ?
Non, non, non.
Parce qu'on reprend tout.
Du coup, ils sont contents,
ça ne dérange pas.
D'accord, okay.
Mais là, ouais,
bah nous, c'est déjà arrivé
que la mairie nous dise de la garder
Mais ça, le problème à transporter,
c'est galère.
Parce que...
Elle est pas volée,
c'est bon.
Ouais, mais ils savent qu'on...
Oui, oui, c'est ça, ouais.
Elle est pas volée, bon.
Ouais, c'est bizarre, alors.
Si vous voulez la racheter...
Ouais, c'est ça.
Oui.
Vous parlez anglais ?
Non.
Non, mais c'est allé, c'est bon.
Ouais, merci.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Vous ramassez tout ça là ?
Ouais, c'est vraiment pour tout.
Il dit que c'est une bonne chose de pêcher à l'aimant
c'est une bonne chose
Nous pouvons appeler la ville.
Ouais.
Euh...
Si ils veulent demander
au propriétaire de la moto
Ouais.
Et peut-être...
Comme elle n'est pas volée on ne sait pas ce que veut faire le propriétaire
Ouais.
Peut-être qu'on peut nous la donner
Ouais, je sais pas.
Ou une grosse récompense
Ouais.
Comme 3 bières ou 4 bières
Ouais, ouais.
Ouais.
Mais c'est...
Ouais, c'est étonnant
parce que c'est un modèle assez chère
Ouais.
C'est très chère
On la revend ?
Je pense qu'elle est morte
c'est mort.
Non, vous pouvez la restaurer.
Ouais, on...
Ouais.
OK.
On on a trouvé une en Angleterre,
et le gars l'a  emmenée à la maison
pour la restaurer.
Ah, ouais ?
On peut faire pareil ?
Ouais.
Tu as vu le résultat ?
Non, je ne l'ai jamais vu.
Ouais, je pense que...
Mais vous pouvez le vendre
au ferrailleur quand même
Ouais.
Ouais, le ferrailleur
C'est trop de travail,
je pense que c'est...
Mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi elle n'est pas déclarée volée
Puis elle est trop lourde
On espère que vous avez apprécié cette vidéo
Merci à Leigh et Nicky de nous avoir accompagnés pour cette pêche à l'aimant
La chaîne Bondi Treasure Hunter est en description de la vidéo, n'hésitez pas à la visiter
A la semaine prochaine